bella stati ragazzi e benvenuti
finalmente finalmente sul parkour che
era da una vita che volevamo fare quello
nuovo polo bello quello fatto bene sono
come nico pietro eccolo qua ciò pietro e
come mai se è così allora tutti qua
penso che sono su qualcuno ragazzi
allora quelli che hanno fatto questa
mappa sono gli stessi che hanno fatto
parti parkour vecchi che avevo fatto con
con il mio amico pietro quindi
sono troppo contento di poter fare
appunto sapa perché www per cui porre la
riferirà questo va fim pirate bay
parkour paradise atto e fatelo sto
spiegando ci sia allora quando sei
pronto entriamo nel nuovo mondo del
parkour ragazzi questo momento epico
perché so che le serie del genere sono
strass egui te e che vi piace quindi so
che stiamo per partire in una roba epica
e sono contenti del forno con il medico
pietro no dobbiamo prima d'entrare oddio
ci vedrà dall'alto adesso si vedrà
dall'alto guarda che cadiamo sicuro
eccoci bellissimo da quanto no pensavo
dire che possono ricadere nel nel vuoto
invece non siamo nel primo amiche e dai
dai
ok allora allora la prima credo che si
faccia così maristi c'è una scala di
trani che nel suo tipo tranquillo e so
già tutto definito ma andando avanti non
so 9 ma spero fenomeno a madonna e
credibile ho fatto però sta dando
importanti perché lo sono anche meno
praticati mariga 6 giornate meno fornito
guarda se lo fa sopra guarda ma dove sei
fino al primo cioè cosa vuol dire
altissima ma sono titoli niguarda via al
trovare altro tai fai ma aspettavi
questo bar di ala forte
non ci credo finito perfetto ma come
l'isola bella mostra un'attenzione l'ha
fatta a ricadi viene sconfitto ragazzi
pazzesco mi piace bellissimo commenta
discreti
i tripidi pie brave grazie non ti
buttano giù perché per ogni livello
adesso devi avere fiducia si sopravvive
o chi adora scendo io la casa della
cavia per ora questa check point ma
stavo in generale perché non dice niente
acqua dietro attuali dire di fare devi
saltare ma non ci è possibile e sarebbe
rompere le scatole alla scala amiche per
rompere le scatole a ok per non protetto
ok
beh ce l'ho fatta per me è facile però
non è finito no non è finito livello che
pensavo fosse video già qua
il ragazzo non si capisce non si capisce
mai i mali sul riciclo si sono delle ma
come c'è futuro
aspetta aspetta per peta è bravo non è
il momento di starnutire le 20 a
chiamarmi scudetti ma che cazzo stato
fisco a fare allora aspetta
no no no cosa succede
sei cascato altri ma ti devi farti tutto
va bene trovata io buona blog l'aspetta
ma ma non è che noi non scherzo no va
bene il postino vabè mai possibile no ma
non è giusto non si può fare stavolta
scusate ma quanti rivederci sono felice
sono 100 ma sono pazzi voi fatto
arrivare fin lì chi può fortuna amico
bravo a vailate che si beve fortissimo e
no non credo fosse quello che riesco a
fare neanche 11 scusa io ti giuro non
riesco a fare neanche il primo ce l'ha
fatta ma che mattina ma che mattina
grazie a qualche ora bastano i balconi
proprio ancora e ancora
capitan ok va bene
bravissimo va bene era giù stime hanno
aspettato che non sono più forti
dobbiamo andare allora perché dritto per
dritto sono caduto io ma non penso che
dovrebbe andare a segno a mettere alla
prova o altro e poi però non lo so sai
non ho idea cacchio sa che non può
andare ma cerca di poter stare io che ne
so la perché poi c'è una prova che possa
arrivare ma da quando il cac io faccio
poi è uguale a dove sei tu a distanza se
io guardo la distanza tra questo ecco
bravo amica aspetta che prova a fare
questo e fino a qualche e poi la parole
quando mi devi arrivare lì dove è lì da
qua però pc card e forte che voglio
tutto lui tutto lui bravi nowgamer avrei
capito usa di fare bravo bravo adesso
poi quando vediamo poi si son rogo
amiche bye bye bye bye gravissimo nice
bravissimo dai aiuto la fatica di mira
incredibile bravi
bravo l'ex co
raga ci abbiamo messo una vita ma ce
l'abbiamo fatta bene ed è in fondo di
bello questo ce ne sono 100 vi dico solo
questo è il 200 e 100 ha detto prima
cento di vecchio e sono uno più
difficile all'altro siamo al terzo
signori questa rai in questo video non
finirà mai però cervello di a questa
serie perché faremo ovviamente più video
e mi sembra un pò è difficile farlo in
un video solo però sono già soddisfatto
e sinceramente di contro abbiamo fatto
adesso però c'è e non sapete andiamo di
qua e non lo so distribuite e io seguivo
la pace lo slime
attenzione allora non capisco e fin qua
e fin qui tutto ok ma no che forse
capito dove non so se non lo so non ne
sono convinto
oh my brother il sì ce l'ho fatta non
solo che devono invece da qua qua
d'acqua e poi da questo fai lo zaino e
si è quindi far facile a dirsi no ma
anche a farsi guarda non è vero ma ecco
doveva essere pestato fighissimo peccato
mamma mamma mia mi che mamma mia una
sola più solo tentativo effettivamente
allora quasta il coso dove mi che è ma
celebrazioni come certamente qua sono
sobri so cosa vai avanti che ahi ahi ahi
ahi ahi acciai dai richiami anche tu se
ci riesce grazie ai atto rende tanto non
sto morendo incredibile niente siamo
come che secondo me non possiamo più
muoverci non siamo bloccati sono
bloccati perché siamo in due nello
spazio di una persona togli chi si morto
come fatta male come in fondo a morire
dove sei non livello di prima
bagarre è allora la vuoi smettere di di
martoriare io so neanche dove sto
andando
ma non lo so sono un pò pazzo posto
facendosi scappare sta roba dall aspetta
uno qui sento che ti stai procurando del
danno fisico però vabbè mi sto
divertendo erano so dove cacchio devo
andare adesso è di vigilare sulla scala
che cioè destra
no è impossibile di fare parchi sicura
comunque solo studiano il parkour e ha
voglia ragazzi porca vacca perché
veramente difficile bellissimo che
giocato ho fatto e adesso io veramente
non capisco la mappa potrebbe essere che
lui o amica e adesso non so super
bravissima e poi e poi penso sopra di
sopra no sopra di nola dove è però e poi
non lo so penso dove sto andando però ci
provo sono da qualche parte in giro va
bene ok non so me la sto facendo
effettivamente non se la passava bene e
vengo giù
cosa ho fatto lì dai che palle sono
stato forse rubata
non che non ho capito il senso di tutto
questo perché l'hanno messa scusami ma
che palle stato di due ore come fate
arrivare fin là devi fare parkour amico
alcun dove che non capace o la re min
chiamate che io ho fatto noto
no però secondo turno
hai capito io ho fatto strada e ho
capito ma dove cazzo mi vedevi forti
vorrei un figlio rapito l'abito avido
bravissimo stop artigiando ok pertugi
pertugi quella quella blu madonna che
male ok madonna che casi è veramente i
ragazzi sembra facile visto mai preso un
casino bravissimo sto per loro in nome
aiutare niente ok sto veramente per
morire la gama non sono morto che è
infra buono ma devo fare il saltino
provi signora via dell'acqua e non
possono più ok c'è qualcosa qua no ok
vado su per visita è fermo per occhio
che dica intorno all'inizio per bocca e
sorretto tra il sanità di palazzo strano
che la prima volta che non mi rovini
gameplay non votando l'isolotto non lo
fa non mi debito non togliamo il pivot
fisso gioco per favore hai visto
qualcosa lì almeno c'è una casa c'è un
pozzo l'aveva sarà libero di parkour ma
non sono riuscito va bene ok va bene
casetta bella siamo al cinema guarda ci
siamo al 5 sull'albero di tradire mai
fatto arrivare da dalla sabbia qua la
terra da ho sbagliato è stata quella
vicino all'acqua dello sport
praticamente dritto vada amiche amiche
ma scusa se con questo tema perché poi
passare in mezzo camera non lo sapevo ok
ok e penso di qui chiesto di qua non di
qualche cosa ma dietro sicuro di chi no
bravissimo grazie all'intuizione sempre
neanche di cogliere dal prova
controllato ma come non puoi arrivare
qua scusa come no
ah no aspetta probabilmente di fare
ora è giusto è giusto vai dritto dritto
dritto dove c'è un piolo lì salta su
quello amici non lo vedevano era così da
fare o c'è un bug penna no penso di sì
penso che sia così proprio vai sul
esatto del noce un così visibile no
perché è uno e mezzo qualcosa quindi non
risolto un po cattivello eccoci amiche
grazie vai vai vai veloce del nice
no perché ci sono nero blocchi visibili
che impediscono di barare però mamma dei
ragazzi la paura è quella che devo
mentre soldi un blog che mi hai trovato
no uno sbaglio un salto ok into devo
rifarmi amiche ok ok
mamma mia mamma mi ricordo solo fare
entro 18 entro nel burro ha subito la
casetta amico guardarle dai nostri mi
aprì e non c'è niente quando avere un
guarda c'è qualcosa dietro il cartello
dove schiacciate a si può uscire di qua
ok e non ha niente prossimo livello di
qua eh vabbè arrivo
devo il cartello rowley meno di mezzo
come casa mette il cartello mi serve
siamo solo al sesto di 100 gioisci amico
abbiamo un semplice da fare sono davanti
semplicità
no ce l'ho fatta amichetto l'avif bravo
mamma mia che sono in un non so spiega
via in game
bravo grazie alla ragazza riesca a fare
sta cosa qua che è altrettanto
incasinata sono sicuro che no da come
incasinata più forse no
e complicato però è bello perché si
riveli quanto non bellissimo alle parti
visto che è male sono vivo solo io
sono vivo ancora per poco ma sono vivo
mi servirebbe dell'acqua sarebbe utile
guardi sono amiche
ciao ciao teramano milan c'e una corda
si sorprende poco di meno te lo faccio
un etero ma infatti difficilissimo ma
continua questa roba
mamma mia mi piace veramente un bordino
sollevazione allora di qua devo arrivare
pro gravissimo è poi arrivato a svelta
oddio oddio è un casino
sei sicuro di provare 4 beta ok sono
sicuro più o meno perché ogni tanto si
fossero ha forse la volevo arrivare al
finale no perché il finale va fatto non
lo so amico non lo so perché qua c'è
qualcosa di strano lo aspetta che
capisco aspetta
sono qui io ma il medagliere mi sa che
devo fare questa cosa qua non so se ci
arrivò però no no no e te lo giuro come
hai fatto fare suddiviso in canzone
d'autore non so aspettati che ci andiamo
in conflitto inter
togliti bijoux palette aspetto vai è il
momento per ai 26 chili a fare cose
strane che no non vado vado io arrivo
circa prossimo la nuova amica e no vabbè
nola per viaggi brevi rivede come devi
devi devi voglio vedere la tua reazione
vieni qua che il mare
ora con tutto lavoro al cos'è sta roba
ma poi ci sono tre mondo ma questa cosa
mi significa non si tra i bottoni
proprio una cosa che però ciao è stato
capito solo di fare no sai dove guarda è
il quello dove di l'angolino in alto
hanno quello di mano sa cosa devi fare
sai cos'è quella si sono così visibili è
esatto e vero ho capito madonna è un
bordello pregio no mannaia me oppure
bello vi piace ebbe il suo livello
marcondirondirondello ok ok ok photonic
usa
ok rifarò x 9 mm pazzesco pazzesco
pazzesco 18 non sarà che non so cosa ho
fatto qui ragazzino bruno quel primo
episodio di il parkour everything col
manico pietro è stato molto complicato
perché il mio amico pietro non mi aiuta
però ciò che si inizia una nuova serie
prima quel palco che avevamo fatto prima
era una sorta di allenamento questo è un
falco che durano un sacco perché tu ci
sono 100 episodi
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi come
se mi è piaciuto vi piace anche vari
social chi e come li notò da sempre la
descrizione se non siete vi era come
sempre ci vediamo ad un prossimo video
bella ragazza
[Musica]